- Un casse-tête logistique
s'annonce sur la Côte-de-Beaupré
le 28 juillet, jour de la visite
du pape François. La route 138
sera complètement fermée pendant
12 heures de 3 h du matin
à 15 h.
- C'est sûr qu'en raison
des entraves, nous on pense
fermer le commerce.
- Les commerçants doivent
déjà planifier en conséquence.
- Nous-mêmes on doit rentrer
dans nos commerces avant 7 h
le matin. Donc, vu que nous on
a des animaux à s'occuper, c'est
sûr qu'on va venir s'occuper
de nos animaux tout ça, mais
je ne crois pas que la boutique
sera ouverte.
ÉMILIE LORD, ministère des
Transports du Québec
- Planifiez vos déplacements,
soit reportez ou encore
devancez.
- Les camions, autobus et
roulottes ne pourront pas
circuler sur une portion
de 25 km entre la côte
de l'Église à Boischatel et la
rue des Montagnards à Beaupré.
L'impact pour les automobilistes
et les cyclistes sera moindre.
En direction est, l'entrave
ne sera qu'entre Château-Richer
et Beaupré. Les voies de
contournement locales seront
mises en place. Mais ça se
complique pour les véhicules
lourds : ils devront emprunter
un important détour vers
le Saguenay. L'industrie
du camionnage s'attend à
des impacts.
MARC CADIEUX, président, Asso.
du camionnage du Québec
- De possibles retards, en
espérant qu'il n'y aura pas
de ruptures de certains
produits, on sait qu'on
transporte les produits
pétroliers et aussi
les produits alimentaires.
C'est de réorganiser
des livraisons, de tenter
peut-être dans certains
cas d'en précéder.
- Un important périmètre de
sécurité sera également érigé
autour du Sanctuaire de Sainte-
Anne-de-Beaupré. Les agents
de la Sûreté du Québec seront
aux aguets.
ANN MATHIEU, porte-parole, SQ
- Le pape François, de par
ce qu'il représente, pourrait
peut-être faire face à des gens
qui pourraient être moins
bien intentionnés, ce qu'on ne
souhaite pas. Mais on se doit
d'assurer la sécurité à tous
points de vue.
- Une visite historique pour
laquelle les autorités invitent
à la patience. La propriétaire
de cette animalerie ne sent fait
pas trop :
- Moi, je ne vois pas que c'est
un désagrément, mais c'est sûr
qu'il faut réorienter.
- Pour ceux qui n'auront pas
le choix de se déplacer, l'état
de la situation sera diffusé
en temps réel sur le site
du ministère des Transports
et celui de la Ville.
Ici Camille Carpentier,